let's jump to this story we got here
from The Daily Mail World Health
Organization warns xbb
0.1.5 what is that why is there a
decimal on the letter is the most
transmissible coveted variant yet as
figures show Strain makes up 70 percent
of cases in northeastern U.S and as I
show you that I'm just going to show you
another article
recession predicted in 2023 for U.S
economy by economists the major Banks so
uh I wonder what their plan is for this
year I'm bullish now
where it's like 2021 2022 2023 and then
you add it up at six six cross out the
zeros and six I believe I believe it the
devil walks Among Us you're a religious
man yeah man tell me about it well so do
you guys think the economy is gonna
gonna collapse you think they're gonna
lock things down with this xpb15 variant
or is this or is this just more hype for
for urban liberal types
like how how dangerous how how is it
actually even hurting people because
some viruses are super transmissible but
they don't do anything to you you don't
even know you have that's usually what
what happens when a virus is very
transmissible it's not as potent it's
not as dangerous the corporate media
automatically with this uh new variant
that they declared that probably was
named by Disney it was it was
fear-mongering immediately saying
there's going to be a huge wave of
hospitalizations the hospitals are being
overflowed people are gonna die and I'm
like okay we've heard this before uh
last year we heard about the winter of
severe illness and death and again I was
here saying it's not going to happen
it's fear-mongering uh a lot of the
early data showing this latest variant
is showing that it doesn't create more
people to be hospitalized it doesn't
kill more people
um so you know we have that data point
there what's going to happen here again
no one has a you know Magic Ball we
don't know what's really going on here
all we know is that we're being screwed
over uh the government has spent too
much money they hyperinflated our
currency you see it in the supermarket
you see everywhere you go you have been
screwed by the banksters and the
politicians that have hijacked to this
economy for their own personal benefit
it's a sinking ship they took all the
silver out of it and now they're just
lighting it on fire kicking you off the
ship and the members are playing the
music I think I figured it out we are in
a simulation and it's called Plague Inc
oh that game they actually stopped the
making or they stopped selling you know
the game play a game where you you
actually are the virus or the pathogen
or whatever the protozoan and then you
have to spread yourself out without
people knowing then you can become as
then you want to try and kill it's
horrible so when covet came out they
were like no we're not doing it anymore
Chinese government stopped selling it in
China at the time and then they made an
expansion called The Cure you know
they're all like on board with like
solving wow talk about a virtue The Cure
yeah it's called Plague Inc colon The
Cure blame them
trying to stop the virus and it might be
multiplayer like one guy plays with the
virus one best friends that'd be cool
actually playing is a fun game The Cure
sounds fun too
um what do you think that we are in a
simulation res I think it's not
impossible I told you earlier whoever
just joined um I think that an alternate
timeline is not out of the question I
think that uh or it's just it's just
some crazy regardless what your religion
is or not like it could be some Messiah
times I don't know what's going on it's
either something we've never seen or
we're just at the end of something we've
seen before you think that's real like
the end times Messiah I'm not a
Christian so I don't believe in
Revelations really but I believe in
something very similar as far as like
yes like uh you know some sort of
Messiah Christians believe it's a return
of Jesus Jews believe it's someone
that's never existed and it's
essentially the same thing and it's just
like um Messianic times where you can
give birth in a day and animals don't
eat each other and we don't fight it's
like this beautiful peace right peace on
Earth heaven on Earth so it's it's
either that's possible or something that
we've already done forever that we've
seen like civilizations die and rise up
again an Empire like either that's or
that's what's that's what we're in store
for or something we've never seen before
there's no in between in my opinion the
weird thing to me is that simulation
theory is becoming so popular because it
is like
if these these these secular liberal
people who are saying like maybe we're
in a simulation I'm like you realize the
moment you entertain that possibility
you are now rejecting every atheist
argument you've made
like call it a simulation call it a
construct call it whatever you want a
higher power created the universe that
you exist in and then it's entirely
possible the universe has only existed
for 5 000 years because it was created
in a simulation I was talking to Charlie
Kirk about this and I was like look when
you play Grand Theft Auto nobody built
those skyscrapers in the game your
little your little dudes running through
Liberty City or whatever there's
buildings everywhere we know those
buildings were programmed by a Creator
and not actually constructed dude you
got to take well I'm not saying you
gotta take mushrooms but if you take
mushrooms that becomes way more apparent
or obvious like it you really see that
this stuff I so you're saying that the
Earth is only five thousand years old
and the fossils are put in the ground as
a test of our face no but you see the
set pieces around you you realize like
this was here this is not I don't know
it doesn't actually I should take that
back it doesn't make it didn't make me
think that we're in a simulation
necessarily but it really distinctified
the non-organic or the non-living things
have you ever taken psychedelics or
mushrooms or anything like that no I
highly would recommend my myself to take
those and anyone I don't want to tell
you what to do Extended State DMT
experiments at universities are
fascinating to me yeah that's what I
want to see more of IV DMT trips and uh
US Government DMT studies are um just
absolutely mind-boggling I would be a
little bit careful Ian about
recommending people to do psychics just
myself I know but but personally it's a
personal Recreation I I know but if
people want to do it they should of
course come to that conclusion
themselves and it's not like doing sled
riding it's it's it's it's a big
spiritual kind of experience that that
again people need to decide and
determine if it's right for them because
for some people it could actually hurt
them yeah uh and we still don't know
what's really going on in this larger
kind of energetic Cosmic dimensional uh
existence that we all have here so a lot
of people say you know you're playing
with something that you don't understand
which you should be extremely careful of
scientifically we are experiencing a
simulation in that our bodies are
simulating stimuli and then giving us
binary data and it's being we're seeing
it we see Vision or we have sound this
vibrate so but are we affecting the
simulation like this one again like NASA
Harriman and the quantum vacuum and look
at like the superstructure of the
universe and and the web of Nature and
things like that we're seeing uh Back to
the Future too bit when Biff is
President yeah of course so like first
of all I would like to ask people
watching and you guys at the table is
there any sequel that's better than the
original that's my first question but
that's my favorite in that scenario but
that's what I feel like we're living in
is where like someone found the almanac
and Biff is the president whether that's
Trump or Biden it's like we are living
through backs of the future too right
now not one not three which was the the
Western [ __ ] it was like number two
is where we're living right now where
it's like gambling's legal Biff is the
president there's it doesn't matter
that's a good point because we have that
remember that book uh Baron Baron Trump
you know that book from the 1800s or
whatever that I still don't believe is
real I'm not familiar with this there's
uh you want to look it up people are
gonna sit Baron Trump is a time traveler
no no no no no no no no no no no no the
baron Trump novels yeah the baron Trump
novels reportedly written in 1889 and
1893 by Ingersoll Lockwood I've not
heard of this and they were they were
obscure until 2017 when they received
media attention for perceived
similarities between their protagonist
and U.S president yeah one of the
stories is about a person named Baron
Trump who becomes president whose base
of operations on Fifth Avenue and a
bunch of socialists and anarchists come
up from the Lower East Side of Manhattan
rioting and like apparently that's in we
I think someone brought the book and
we're looking through it I'm like this
has got to be a hoax but people are
saying no no what happened is
Steve Bannon is Baron Trump from the
future you guys have heard that
conspiracy theory right that makes sense
that makes sense yeah I've not heard
this one but so he came back to warn us
about the Federal Reserve you're
teaching me a lot I love it yeah yeah
Steve Bannon well Donald Trump's Uncle
does have a connection with uh Tesla
Nicholas Tesla and um anything could
could be possible yeah he didn't he was
involved in the FBI going to raid in
Tesla's lab and getting all this like he
was the first one Trump's uncle was the
first one to
um uh be in Tesla's room after he you
know passed they went in took all Tesla
stuff then all of a sudden the UFO
crashes in Roswell like 15 years later
or something or 20 years later and
they're like it was a hot air balloon
guys don't worry about it we don't have
drones so Tesla invented time travel
you're saying Trump was the first one he
discovered we'll say radio for sure and
uh the vibrational technology maybe they
used in Atlantis too no that's what
Randall Carlson seems to think or this
is hinting at
um but I I don't know but what I'm
thinking is my new my best conspiracy
theory now the best new one is that the
ancient cultures Before the Flood 13 14
000 years ago had not explosion
technology like combustion they didn't
have that they had implosion technology
where they could vibrate the Earth and
send electricity electrical current
through the Earth through the air that's
different from implosion what do you
mean well by using implosive forces this
is what Randall refers to it as
implosion Tech you you compress it so so
much and even like a lattice like a a
fiend lattice like graphene or something
that it creates a vibration and then you
can vibrate things and get a current out
of it and that they've that one of the
great nations of the time maybe it was
Atlantis decided we're going to war
we're to keep control and they use that
technology in war and vibrated the Earth
in such a way that its protective forces
diminished its field dropped and the
meteors fell onto the planet and
annihilated it so don't mess the other
the explosion apocalypse would be
nuclear war right but the the implosion
apocalypse would be commentary impact I
like the conspiracy theory that it
wasn't Ancient Aliens it was humans and
Earth was terraformed you ever hear that
one that's a fun one thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time